[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
the jar is not full this is our
disgusting daily show that keeps you
updated on exactly what is happening in
nerd news like these topics that are
coming up on the show today of course we
just got miss marvel episode four it was
a doozy and it seems like we're going
back in time baby um we also have to
talk about some crazy doctor doom news
we don't know we'll see we'll talk about
it we're gonna get to it um we're also a
little eight on some harley quinn season
three updates that we want to let you
know about if you haven't heard if
you've been living under a rock or you
know don't watch that show and that's
your chance to check it out and
if you weren't sick of it yet
which or not
it's morbid time
maybe the movie that will never die
because it's the highest grossing film
of all time trillion dollars oh there's
more beats therefore i don't even know
if you can see it sorry um
some housekeeping things
before we start so serious
yeah taking the mood down
there was an insane clip of barbie
posted online today it was one of those
spy shots we we talked about barbie
we talked about marvel on the show um
datsun this is a poll request that i'm
throwing at you with absolutely no
notice i apologize do you guys care
enough about barbie for us to show this
clip we know it's the biggest movie of
all time next to morbius
but you know
we don't want to open saturate you guys
we don't want to send any spoilers out
but it is a crazy clip it is a crazy
clip so i'm putting it to you guys there
will be a poll in the chat let us know
are we showing the bbw thank you mo in
the chat are we showing the bbw clip it
is your call also on yesterday's show i
was dumb and i got two characters from
miss marvel confused i got najma and
aisha confused and that led to us having
a discussion that made a lot of sense in
my head
alert fake nerd if you know me at all um
i'm i would also be the kind of person
to get bruno confused with brian so
parker of course i'm dumb and that leads
me to a congratulations to koi
for winning our prediction segment on
the show i thought about that yeah we
saw the dragon in the flashback it was
the prediction i would have gotten it
wrong either way and it felt good to be
so invested in our own bet with
ourselves last night at one in the
morning that's really like victory sleep
i um i didn't introduce my lovely
co-hosts we've got nana vanston hello
how goes it uh just to make it perfectly
clear my relationship with grimace was
never sexual
can we also make it perfectly clear your
outfit is perfectly
aligned i just want to give credit
i am a closet cosplaying uh kamala from
like the first two scenes but i couldn't
find a picture so but just trust me but
we got i like that style that's nicely
done i'm so happy that we make this show
before i introduce koi 72
people said yes to the barbie clip so
we'll get into that in a second um
speaking of names i may or may not be
pronouncing correctly we have coy jandro
on the show that's the american way of
saying it okay we say genre you say
android tomato tomato i respect the
effort thank you
it's like a star wars name it's all
about i get cost my last name is costa
but everyone wants to call me costa so
uh we're different vowels and different
people you understand the struggle use
the answer for both i even answered to
cody at this point okay corey cody
there's no too we're gonna call you
whatever we want and i also want to say
a very quick thank you to kirk ingersoll
who might be in the chat today uh super
generous um super chatter but never says
anything so but thank you sometimes we
don't get to people who don't leave
little messages um i just want to say
special thank you to you let's get into
the show
speaking of super chats we have a
reverse square jar i'm not going to
spend any more time on it if you know
you know um
play the headlines graphic baby there it
is i love it i love it let's not keep
them waiting you guys we got a new clip
from not a clip but a behind the scenes
look at the
barbie movie sort of related to what we
saw yesterday can we just roll it
what's the scream for me some people
talk about citizen kane some people talk
about goodfellas godfather but to me
it's gossling in barbie that's really
going to change cinema because that to
me i mean you we were talking right
before air the snl era when he was doing
uh the other guys the the gosling scream
is our modern willem scream like wilhelm
scream and it's so beautiful it's
amazing and just like that the comedic
timing this barbie movie's gonna be off
the chain i'm so psyched i i genuinely
think this will be my favorite i think
it's coming out this year i hope it is i
think it's going to be my favorite movie
of the year i'm getting a phone call i'm
not taking i'll take it
on your watch
speaking of new things a new trailer for
harley quinn season three was released
by hbo max yesterday
um we didn't talk about on the show
because we were on barbie watch um and
as we always all know
already
for barbie watch um
they also released some of the episode
titles for the upcoming season if you
are interested at all
in the harley quinn show um
you can go find us online we're not
going to read them all here um if you're
not interested at all in the harley
quinn show you should be it's so much
incredible
one of my favorite things that that dc
is putting out i think it's one of the
best thing dc's ever done yeah it's got
a ivy and harley as a little couple it's
cute
it's also like
a little
messed up it's so crunchy it's like
adult irreverent and it's also the tone
that i've always felt harley quinn
should could be like they nailed like
what her perspective of gotham is it's a
really great way to keep the batman
brand fresh by not having too much
batman that's true very fair that's very
fair speaking of keeping things fresh uh
elizabeth olsen wants to come back for
round
five
of the scarlet witch let's see we've got
age of ultron we've got infinity war
we've got endgame we've got civil war
skipped that one uh we've got one
division we've got doctor strange round
seven seven let's go that's impressive
she's sketching up to hugh jackman
that's right that's right um she said in
an interview this week that she would
love to do an adaptation of the witches
road
comic run if you're not familiar here's
what she had to say about it she said
there's a few images in my head i think
they're from witches road and she's
aging and she's decaying while she's
using her power and there's something in
that this older woman who's aging from
her power that i'm really interested in
i don't really know what that means but
i would kind of love to be old
which is incredible and i do think like
this is a great dovetail from her sort
of corruption by the darkhold into
uh you know something like this where
it's just like sort of eating away at
her and she's just like i also love that
this means that in between roles she's
reading comics like this is a very
specific arc i talked to her during the
press tour of multiverse of madness and
i was saying that she's always so
invested in the arcs of whatever she's
reading she talks about interviews she
brought up house of m way back in the in
the first introduction for character
days and when i asked her what she was
interested in adapting next she's like
i'm actively reading and looking for
stuff and now this comes out which means
i love that liz olson is just somewhere
like flipping through comics finding out
her source and she says she says i would
love to be old even if this doesn't
happen elizabeth olsen i i don't think
you have to worry it's gonna happen
eventually well
it all catches up with us
unless you are she's
and i got in a heated conversation about
how old cher was yesterday and i feel
like that's another one where i think
she's like crazy she's like in she's
like 78.
um
we've got a poll going in the chat which
would you rather see house of m or
witch's road we got a little taste of
house of m and some story lines but
people really want that no more mutants
line and so do i also you can do like
the the different multiverse options now
that we've introduced multiverse you
could have the different worlds of house
event which be interesting i just want a
world where magneto's child is wanda
maximoff and
that's all that's it that's it that's
one of the things
simple pleasures could have been a line
of dialogue with patrick stewart could
have been right there like i know a
wanda blah blah it could have been a
line
um
switching universes for a minute obi-wan
kenobi we talked about this a little bit
yesterday the original writer of the
screenplay has been doing some
interviews and we got some interesting
details about what the film
might have been um
you know it sounds like the ending was
going to be a little bit different um
the the writer said you know in the
original draft rifa didn't know that
vader was anakin and sort of grew up
hating the jedi because she saw a jedi
anakin skywalker walking toward her
killing younglings stabbing her and then
saw sort of these clone troopers during
order 66 just like merkin jedi's and was
like great thank you so much for saving
us um and so she grew up hating the jedi
order which i think is like a pretty
cool motivation for her character um
you know some of that did end up making
it into the screenplay um and he he went
on to say so it was obi-wan kind of
letting her in on that secret you know
that vader is anakin and that revelation
uh makes her kind of go oh my god i've
been wrong this whole time so she ends
up going back and basically saving
kenobi by sacrificing herself she goes
to vader and says i killed kenobi and
then you know she knows that's going to
trigger a little bit of rage in in vader
and then vader would have killed rifa
allowing
uh obi-wan to escape and that sort of
would have been her story
uh
so straightforward
but you know a little bit of simplicity
he also says that riva would have been
the only inquisitor in that story so so
no you know grand inquisitor
no
fourth brother i can't remember um you
know none of those rebels characters
would have been in this film um which is
which is interesting i like this idea a
little bit more because it does feel
like it's more uh one linear as much as
it sounds complicated but it also allows
us to really empathize with her more
directly instead of that like oh will
they won't they complication and i also
kind of like the idea like it doesn't
make sense you'd know anakin and it also
doesn't make sense she's hunting for him
in a way yeah just that that line didn't
quite work for me it was i thought it
was interesting right it felt like she
we knew she had her own motivations the
whole time it kind of felt like she was
playing both sides i don't know how
perfect well i came across being
executed i do think like you know you
make a movie you have two hours and
having like these three people being the
main characters i guess four if you
include leia um makes a lot of sense but
then when you break it out into you know
a six episode series you gotta add some
add a little bit of context for some of
these people so it totally makes sense
but uh you know i think lucasfilm is
learning a lot of lessons with the
content that they're making right now
and i hope that that means that we're
going to get some really cool stuff in
the future and you know maybe this is
one they're like oh maybe we should have
done this one as a movie and they were
like oh solo maybe we should have done
that one as a series so also they can do
an obi-wan too as a movie like they're
not stuck in a format and they should
it'd be great absolutely we should
people want it just because it's here
doesn't mean it can't go there next yeah
um we're going back to marvel um some of
the
uh jeremy slater the writer the head
writer of moon knight uh gave an
interview about sort of how his gods fit
in with the gods of thor love and
thunder they were kind of writing these
two projects at the same time and they
didn't know how one was gonna fit in
with the other in terms of release date
so they were like playing this weird
dance with the studio
um and i suppose he he says you know
they intentionally made no real
connections because they didn't know
what was going to happen so they talked
to kevin feig and kevin feige was like
just go play in your own little sandbox
and we'll figure out the rest later um
so we talked about this a little bit on
the show yesterday i'm very excited that
marvel is like really opening this box
up and being like yeah there's gods and
there are a lot of them and we're gonna
do some crazy stuff with them and but
we're gonna give them to you in little
pieces first
before we kill them all or whatever and
kind of like we were talking about
yesterday all of this undercurrent of
gods last night of the episode we
couldn't have predicted that that veil
discussion kind of implies a lot more
yeah so i think the way we're looking at
phase four i do think that is the main
through line of phase four and i think
we're getting closer and closer to
feeling it you're right we want a god
war are we gonna get a god war i mean
boy are we getting a god there's a
certain character that left being a god
because it was beneath him that
apparently might be getting some sort of
property in the mcu so i could see that
i think
it might be time oh
should we discuss let's just get it doom
all right you lovelies early this
morning howard stern accidentally broke
the news rumor that he's involved with
the mysterious doctor doom now dr doom
is an incredible character but before we
discuss him let's play that clip
miserable about it
that's what i did on america's got
talent
[Music]
i uh love this clip because it is
clearly a hot mic and i personally am
not a spoiler guy i usually don't report
on things that still are confirmed i
don't like to lean into that and marvel
this is one of the weirdest leaks that
could happen because it's literally like
people talking about a schedule like
this is such a weird errant moment i
think it's like really safe to say
we don't know what this is we don't know
if this is a video game a a podcast a
movie a play like a fan phil yeah you
know
kevin feigeman
uh so what do you guys think i
personally think if this exists in the
mcu it's gonna be howard stern as howard
stern i see the movie they make as a
giant political commentary on the world
i'd introduce doctor doom personally in
black panther i would have him as a
parallel to namor i'd introduce naymore
and doctor doom simultaneously that way
you see the greater world of the
political element that is black panther
especially as you're passing the torch
of him being a leader so you'd need
other leaders you'd need a kind of
political illuminati i'd have doom in
there and i'd introduce them well before
fantastic four because you're already
gonna be doing a lot in the fantastic
four movie you need the doom presence to
be the entire mcu as a whole so what
better way to do that than have someone
that's iconic in the media space in the
interview space than howard stern as
howard stern do we know his resume
howard stern like he made a movie is he
an actor dirty jobs i mean i know he
he's like obviously a radio
or dirty something
i think he directed and like started a
movie oh and like i was thinking of that
micro discovery channel i would love
that no i think there was like a dirty
work maybe i'm only so old i feel like
there's no way there's no way he's like
doctor doom i don't think they would
risk giving him a main role
i totally agree with you there's no way
he's playing doctor but do we all think
it's live action or do we think it's
maybe voice over work or is it a cartoon
i think if you're reading between the
lines here which you know we love to do
again all this is unconfirmed i'll say
it to save my co-workers for getting in
trouble um
he's talking about the schedule and it
being a pain for his schedule and that
only tells me that it's live action
right like if you were doing voice over
work it was for a video game maybe the
motion capture for a video game would be
hard to schedule around if you can hear
a siren in the background it's marvel
coming they're coming they've found us
we're so sorry yeah uh but this this if
you're just doing voiceover you just
show up in the booth and do your lines
by yourself right um
there's a poll in the chat do you think
howard would make a good doctor
of you said no i think we're all
emotionally in agreement here i also
think we're we probably don't expect
that to be the case no
they wouldn't risk it like they have
good actors playing the villain i'm
sorry sorry okay shots fired at howard
very experienced you know very
experienced actors who were like you
know total pros i'd say we talked
yesterday about like some casting ideas
and choices and the one i forgot to
mention was javier bardem i've got a
whole list
but i do think what you need is someone
that's going to be terrifying to
everyone and i don't find howard stern
to be necessarily everyone's fear and
you need someone like javier berdama
rufus sewell a michael shannon someone
that's larger than life and a big
personality howard stern if it's like uh
narrative podcast because those are
doing really well if it's something
where it's literally just his voice
maybe but i also love that this is
through a hot mic like to me this is the
funniest of like oh man this is a rough
way to find out a big thing yeah we'll
see if howard stern uh has to sort of
issue a press release tomorrow or or
maybe he doesn't have a show tomorrow uh
no kidding um yeah it's it's such a
weird situation that this came out um i
also think what's really interesting is
he calls it doctor doom which makes me
think maybe it's not a holy script solo
yeah no holly did it did it full doctor
doomscript and i would argue that we
need to end the mcu start introducing
villains in singular format we need to
start having villain movies because one
of the strengths of daredevil is that
you're as invested in wilson fisk as you
are in matt murdock you care about the
punch landing twice because you feel the
pain of both of them just wanting their
city doom isn't exactly sympathetic but
he's a leader he's someone that's almost
like a cult leader he's got all of
latveria behind him they believe in him
they follow him you need time to tell
that story i think introducing doctor
doom separate a fantastic four i would
do a soft introduction of black panther
then do a solo project then fantastic
four that way when you actually have the
conflict it feels like a thanos level
threat because he is a thanos level
threat i think people myself included
would argue that infinity war is already
kind of the thanos you know stand-alone
movie or whatever you kind of see him do
his hero's journey of putting all these
infinity stones together and then you
get end game which is like the heroes
side right and
thanos wins at the end of it right it's
his movie yeah and and yeah i would love
to see
more you know villain focused uh
uh projects in the mcu and i think this
would be a great series it'd be a lot of
fun i think dude
can sometimes be sort of sympathetic
depending on you know in that like way
that you know you sit there and be like
villains got a good point
what's interesting about him is like if
they do the original continuity like i
love the original introduction the
character because he had like a scratch
on his face and he was so vain he was so
narcissistic he was so egotistical that
was enough to make him feel like he had
to hide it later on they retconded made
his whole face card and everything else
but i love the ego of doom being his
kryptonite i love that being fleshed out
over a whole movie i wouldn't want to
see like fantastic four fighting a guy
he's like a little scratching his face
like you need to go into the pathos of
that you need like a jake gyllenhaal
nightcrawler performance and i think you
need two hours for that and i also think
that if you're going to be introducing a
character that's doctor strange meets
black panther because the mysticism and
the politics and the leadership you
don't want to do that in a 20-minute
cutscene right and i think like taking
the x-men or mutants out of it like the
characters that people have been
clamoring for in terms of mcu villains
were you know thanos although we got
that very with that teased very early
but then also king the conqueror and
doctor doom yeah like and like it would
be such a shame right it'd be such a
shame to
just have him as a one-on-one movie i
don't think it sounds like they're not
doing that much sense
yeah i mean it's an interesting way to
find out uh but if they did have this as
a one-off what if it's the 838 world and
what do you want to see howard stern
versus john krasinski he's he's already
noodled
but we can do time travel who knows what
the howard stern with the hair
and noodley krazynski yeah and then
rayne wilson is doc or something like
we're just going for that would be fun
steve carrell is like a really enigmatic
howard uh human torch we're just putting
the officers
yeah it's a weird thing to find out this
way but i'm excited so i guess the ques
you bring up a38 the question sort of is
again two actors that we don't really
think will be playing these two
characters what would a dr doom howard
stern movie look like with a john
krasinski
reed richards that's a lot of comedy
it's not going to be doctor david he's
not actually not but if we
i think he's playing himself i think i
think he's going to be interviewing doom
and i think it's going to be a
conversation of like maybe he even gets
killed by doom maybe there's you know a
moment of maybe that's why the
schedule's hard i'm in i'm in reid pulse
is a question for you koi he says
how big will dr doom affect the mcu
outside of any fantastic four projects
uh i think that he would affect the
entirety of leading into secret wars
he's the one that invents battle world
so in secret wars the newest one
well because secret wars the original in
the 80s he's integral he's a very big
part of it he's an even bigger part of
2016 secret wars which is technically
secret wars 3 which is what i think
they're leading up to and that's battle
world he invents this world so basically
there's incursion events which we saw
teased in doctor strange where different
realities collide with each other so
when those two earths collide there's
this moment of split and basically the
planets explode he's able to tether a
bunch of planets together and create
this battle world which is effectively
like a video game where villains and
heroes fight each other in the original
80s one the beyonder who i want mark
hamill to play very bad in a jumpsuit
has basically chess board pieces where
he's pitting villain against hero that's
where spider-man gets his original black
suit you've got a beautiful iconic
iconic image of hulk holding up this
mountain there's a lot of beautiful
imagery i think will come into secret
wars but as far as storyline i think
it's going to be the modern 2016 secret
wars which i think is what the russo
brothers are going to come back to do so
you need to introduce dr doom solo you
introduce doctor doom with mysticism
introduce doctor doom via fantastic four
and then by the time we get to battle
world he's earned that thanos level
threat and then we feel the entire mcu
fearing what he can be and what he has
become which is a god boy is drafting
phase five right here right now
playing the show he's playing in
interviews that the russo brothers gave
in like 2017
being like yeah
it's like charlie day but right here do
you think that secret wars is the
project that brings in
you know the fox x-men movies phases one
through three of of the mcu with some of
the characters that are not in the mcu
anymore i'm talking about like you know
uh tony stark and uh probably uh having
you know old cap come in maybe younger
um and you know the sony ssu and i
missed the spumcy name the ssu
and you know sony's sort of rainyverse
stuff do you think that we'll get it all
in in that project i think that we get
deadpool first and and there it is
there's the overhead cam there's so i
think deadpool is how we acknowledge fox
and i honestly think deadpool being
r-rated like i said yesterday in here
allows r-rated characters to be
introduced because you want to have your
your midnight sons are but i think
that's a taste and then i think the way
you get the movie that a lot of people
thought doctor strange was going to be
is in having secret wars have incursion
events where you get the the cameotastic
journey and i think secret wars needs to
be a two-parter just like infinity war
in-game but i also think that launching
point allows for a new world of x-men
and everything i think it is not just a
phase four ending it's a phase five
beginning i think it's gonna wrap up
everything we've seen to date uh you
might hate me for this would you ever do
a sort of like potentially out of cannon
or like side
cannon
show of secret wars and you could kind
of do some sort of weird practice that's
what what if is to me and i think that
what they're doing with phase four which
is what if season two they've said that
what if season one was largely phase one
through three sure i think what if
they've said very publicly is about
phase four is that i think it's a a
basically set up for an alternate
universe secret wars but i think what
we're gonna get with
the mcu going forward is you can't keep
all these actors for 20 years there
needs to be a big ending so i think
young avengers uh dark avengers
thunderbolts everything we're leading up
to is going to culminate in secret wars
because you're going to have villains
that we feel for because of thunderbolts
and you're gonna have them fighting
heroes that we feel for and then you've
got characters like doom who deserves
his own movie and battle world is gonna
feel like all of that that's not a
two-hour jaunt it needs to be at least
maybe it's a trilogy like they can go
crazy
that's what i would do i love this i
love this people say the nc is running
out of ideas but they're just they just
got started he's got three films in his
backyard i'm writing right now let's do
this and
speaking of
things that we love
where do i get my energy from my
manicness welcome to anna's ad zone give
me the athletic greens john's already
made it this time so we don't have to
witness that absolute train wreck again
we only get to witness this absolute
train wreck what do you need to be an
absolute train wreck like me well the
energy part at least comes from athletic
greens that's the good part not the bad
part we want to think i'm now starting
the ad copy yeah we want to thank
athletics great youth hoca
we want to thank athletic queens for
sponsoring the break room today we've
been taking ag-1 from athletics greens
to help boost our immunity and give us
so much energy throughout the day with
one you heard me right one less than two
one delicious scoop of ag1 you're
absorbing 75 high quality vitamins
minerals whole foods soup whole foods
super my favorite grocery store whole
foods
source superfoods i got through it
probiotics and adaptogens i flew right
through that
time to help you start your day
right the right way this special blend
of ingredients now i'm looking at the
camera now i'm looking at the
teleprompter of ingredients supports
your gut health your nervous system your
immune system your energy recovery focus
aging uh oh
oh i will talk about how i incorporate
aging one in my life well mostly what i
like to do personally anna vance style
is sit and stare lovingly and john as he
sips his ag-1 how can you not look at
that face transformation
so frothy and delicious a little bit on
my nose and i'm talking about
transformation i'm not talking about aj1
i'm talking about john frothy and
delicious so let's talk about ag one h1
is lifestyle friendly do you like to
hula hoop drink it whether you eat keto
paleo vegan dairy free or gluten free it
supports better sleep quality and
recovery mental clarity and alertness
you gotta have that or spies will sneak
up on you and get you it's cheaper than
getting all the different supplements
yourself you're investing in an
all-in-one nutritional insurance
have
your
your apartment could burn down but your
nutrition will stay
the same as long as you take that if
there's a fire like take this out with
you um and for every person or oh
or keep one of these bad boys
you only have to be careful not to catch
on fire yourself then yeah yeah that's
too much carbon that's negative you
don't want that no cap i keep one of
these travels in my car if i like have
it really poorly i legit do so wow you
should have done the personal personal
incorporation
yeah you're on it i haven't even gotten
to the best part yet for every purchase
we donate to organizations helping to
get nutritious food to kids in need
french fries no that ain't nutritious
angie one baby including no kids hungry
here in good ol america which
right now it's time to reclaim your
health and arm your immune system with
convenient daily nutrition every single
gosh darn day so important it's just one
scoop one
scoop in a cup of water every day that's
it
no need for a million different pills
and supplements to look at for your
health and
this is where i start to like here we go
here's the here we go
is going to give you a free one-year
supply of immune supporting vitamin d
and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase
all you have to do to redeem that is
visit athleticgreens.com
break room again
athletics because you're not oh i
thought we were doing it
oh yeah
i'm like what does this look mean how do
i help you never listen when i say it so
i always have to say it again again koi
that is athleticgreens.com
break room to take ownership over your
health and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance really driving
home that insurance that insurance thing
this is a freebie for athletic greens uh
two things
they give you a free one-year supply of
vitamin d the last time i went to the
doctor he was like all you need to
change
vitamin d my man i was like can't i just
go in the sun and he was like look how
white you are stay inside take a
supplement so thank you to athletic
greens for that cover yourself an
athletic group
that's the trick
but i have a second thing that i was
gonna say but i fully forgot it um
speaking of fully forgetting things i
haven't forgotten about new rockstar is
going to be in
canton going to be in texas this weekend
as a part of the rooster teeth extreme
uh austin twenty energies it's coming
and it's coming
the rtx austin 2020 podcast festival
that's happening from july 1st i think
that's in two days through july 3rd if
you've ever wanted to meet some of your
favorite new rockstars hosts in person
uh now's your chance i said meet this
copy says c i don't know what it'll be
tommy might be in a cage so you might
not be able to approach it honestly
tommy is very he likes to meet people he
likes to meet people but he also likes
athletic grades
to kill
so
um
new rockstar is going to be there we're
going to be there in person this group
of people unfortunately will not but you
will have thomas michael bechtold you'll
have jessica clemens you will have
philip molina you will have
[Music]
will be there uh and if you want to save
some money to see aaron vos uh you can
go to the description of this video use
the uh click on that link use the promo
code new rockstars just one word and um
hopefully we'll see you there that is
happening this weekend they're gonna do
a very fun show the only way you'll ever
be able to see it is if you sweat your
little taint off
right off is that a sweater i need my
tapes this white little tate's off in
texas this weekend
no
we've got
yeah sweet little j dove in texas
um we've gotten through the most fun
part of the break room the ad reads but
we're on to the second most fun part
mandatory fun play the
graphic it is all right you
[ __ ] how what are we at what do
we have with these no we haven't gotten
embarrassing today okay we haven't
really been we haven't really been
plugged in juicing yeah we've gotten uh
let's juice it a little baby
i feel like this is not good for us
that's a gift it's morbid time today
gotcha uh in a recent interview with
comicbook.com uh they they interviewed
the film's vfx that's virtual effects
supervisor
joel
uh who addressed the original ending and
the reason but you really didn't like
write this out for me at all huh
he was talking about how the original
ending of morbius uh was was changed
they had to do reshoots you have a photo
from a trailer of what the original
ending was supposed to be
look at just a photo it's just a photo
it was gonna take place in central park
you yelled at me about not writing it so
no i'm not no
i'm talking about it's gonna big place
in central park and the director
was like um what if it was underground
you said they changed it it is a little
more on brand for more videos
more of this doesn't go to park so are
we kidding
so we're skipping this big quote uh the
important part is well yeah okay you
read that part we have but here's the
important part and here's where the real
fun comes in if i don't fall apart
before we get there we have
the script of the original ending i was
um
disrespectful enough to draw a tiny
morbius on the back of it but the
problem is is that some of it got
blanked out what does that mean there
was there's some blood on it there's
some blood right right
that's what blanked out means we got
some blood on it so um we're gonna fill
in those blanks just based off of memory
from seeing it uh john and coy saw it
beforehand i am just puzzled i didn't
see it so i need to ask some questions i
think we can also ask the chat maybe a
couple of yes
chat i think uh you didn't read it but
just intuiting using your psychic
morbius powers i bet that you can also
help so we are playing a little game
called normius mad libs today
i think what we're gonna how we're gonna
incorporate chat here is that we want
y'all to start working on the very last
word uh you're gonna enter it in chat
and our lovely dashiell is gonna is
gonna pick those up and when we get to
the end we will select one of those
so
for you chat i could have sworn you were
gonna switch cameras all right for you
chat
uh we need y'all to start suggesting a
verb
i don't i feel like this spoils it yeah
can i just suffer ending in ing yeah
yeah okay and a verb ending in ing
that's what we need for mule
boom
uh meanwhile from youtube do you want to
go like take turns yeah
okay all right from john
i need a verb that ends in s from you
this is
mad libs and a classic mad libs word i
will not have us not use it
is farts oh great great you're gonna by
the way you're making me say all of this
i just want to point that out
you're the actor i need a liquid from
you my friends well that is that could
be many things
what direction do i want i can get it
after the break room i need a now
let's go with um
that's for my own personality
let's go with whale semen
good very specific
good good good all right uh john hit me
with that i love all of these other
people are going through the comments
and so many things are getting hidden
there's so many things youtube is not
for bad lifts
oh no they're all getting deleted
and dashiell and dodson are like oh no
if someone typed what i said it would
not have made that yeah yeah
okay uh john hit me with the adjective
please uh adjective that's something
that describes a noun um
you mother truckers are lucky there are
no adverbs in here oh man those are the
best ones
thirsty
uh
thirsty yeah yeah yeah bud yeah bud
location
boston
boston
i will be reading it like you went from
incredibly specific to incredibly
general
the united states
space boston landfill burst
jonathan would you mind giving me a verb
that ends in ing
much like the chad is doing i'm so
tempted to say farting oh i'm gonna grab
one the first thing i see from the
uh chat it's uh
uh grass uh gasping okay gasping is so
much better than grasping
all right
chad y'all got a freebie on that one um
now this one's interesting i don't know
what this means way of speaking
oh yes oh is it like whispering shouting
okay so like
hurriedly
well that's not quite right i think that
might fit would it not because that's a
way of speaking okay uh in hushed tones
like whispered maybe well that's the
less fun way to say that it's but
whisper i hurriedly whispered okay
okay
uh i oh we just found out i don't know
how to spell hurdly that's okay
that's okay i spelled it correctly trust
me um adjective john
you just you came up with one we're
switching adjectives adjective um uh
it's a hard one it's so many options
um
and you have to make it funny oh you
would i did you absolutely you had to
and a noun
a noun
i don't remember where this was in the
script because that's what we're trying
to do we're trying to be accurate right
yeah um
i'll say
it's really just any person
way easier than adjectives i'll just say
bat
okay all right that was almost certainly
in the original morbius ending uh can i
get a verb from you coy
um
man i just mad lives are gotta be sexual
i'm gonna go thrusting oh uh okay
playing a very different game okay uh
and a verb past tense um
that's ending with an ed eaton
oh you proved me wrong
oh yeah interesting okay
it's morbius interesting uh a verb
ending in ing and then we're getting a
chats verb ending in ing
um
yodeling oh i like it
i love it
uh and then
do we have some collected ones i don't i
don't see them pulled up but i'll go
through a few of them it's it's you you
asked joshua to do it it should have
been you should have asked oh don't get
me wrong confused i've got no no i
didn't get confused they got their jobs
confused i've got uh throbbing in here
i've got soiling in here
i've got
um
i don't know i've got boiling in here i
like soil i like soiling
oh here's some i've got knitting beading
spooning tweaking thank you dotson i i
misspoke
he's doing a great job
you're going throbbing uh well if you
all both like spoil and spoiling is that
what's soiling like soil ones
all right i'll go i'll majority rules
here okay all right
we have recreated the script here we go
this was the end this is the end action
of morbius originally
morbius farts from the roofs of new york
with whale semen dripping from his mouth
hello milo morbius says didn't expect to
see you in this thirsty boston i could
have moderated that one a little bit
better
enough with the gasping michael milo
currently whispered oh
hurley whispered you can't stop me i'm
the most moist bat alive more base and
milo thrust when the dust settles milo
is eaten
yodeling morbius says i'm sorry milo
it's soylent
that's pretty good scene that's a black
hard cut that's a great ending wow i
think that's fifty shades of morbid time
right there i love yeah i love that um
they started thrusting and then one of
them was eaten at the end that's some
animals usually you go in reverse oh oh
you were talking about that yeah
um about something oh i see different
kind of yeah i was going prank you guys
miss marvel episode 4
jesus chris
we made some art uh i really thought
that tommy being gone would put us back
on track no
somehow that happened
no this marvel episode four came out
last night uh and we have a lot to we
want to talk about there were chase
scenes there were training montages
there were romantic campfires ahead of
time before we jump into this are there
going to be spoilers in this section yes
okay it should be said spoilers abound
about look at that mortise
watch the episode before this yeah yeah
man come back to this
yeah um pause go watch the episode come
back um or
get spoiled
i don't care
get spoiled
um
and of course kamala uncovering a lot
more about her family history in
pakistan while they're there um
can i get from you guys just sort of
like
your initial
thoughts
oh okay i thought you were going to ask
for maybe an accent
of some kind of virginia verb
yeah i had so much fun this series
continues to surprise me continue iman's
freak every time she smiles i'm like a
heart melts she's the best so many
cuties at that campfire um
i don't know if i'm allowed to say that
they were all over 18. so many love
interests
it's you know it's a it's a it's a show
for teenagers i think i don't know i'm
enjoying it
did this episode with her sort of like
them introducing the new love interest
did it change your mind about the other
love interest i like that there's a bit
of a love triangle i really enjoy that
it's almost a square tell us the squares
yeah she's a volume depends on bruno
bryan yeah but uh definitely depends on
bruno i think that it does a really good
job capturing that innocence of when you
have like crushes that are just crushes
like when you're just like googling eyes
at someone we're just like
i a lot of shows try and this one's
succeeding i think largely because the
cast is so strong i also think like
we're giving that to the show
every time i
so stupid every time i see a new like
potential love interest i'm like ooh
good for her i don't think they
purposefully make it seem that way and i
will say it makes it it makes it more
realistic that she's making dumb choices
because she thinks guys are hot like
relatable [ __ ] relatable freaking
we're not there yet come on get us
through but the comic does that too like
the comic does a really good job where
you're like will they won't they and
then like her having multiple people
she's squirrelly about there's a lot of
like mental like those thought bubbles
of her being all adorable there's a lot
of the covers that are like one of the
introductions to this character is a
cover of the two of them like wrapped up
in his scarf and she's like spooning and
they're they've really captured the
innocence of miss marvel really well and
i think that is a lot of amandalani like
i this girl is so interesting she's so
good one of the most interesting things
that i i mean i think we all probably
found this one of the most interesting
things
uh when she gets sort of
the the bangle gets stabbed and then she
sort of gets like heated into this
vision or or the past whatever it is
um a couple of things that were really
interesting in that scene first of all
all the blue smoke that was coming out
of the train mixed with some you know
normal sort of like gray hollywood smoke
from a train station
there was a lot of blue smoke and they
didn't really make anything of it but of
course like there's no way they were
just like yeah let's do blue today yeah
um
so that was really interesting practical
extras yeah i really liked seeing a
scene that looked like it was really
filmed somewhere totally um and then you
know one of the more interesting things
is
you know we have this story of her
grandmother being led back to the train
by this trail of light we had sort of
speculated in the past that this trail
of light might have been related to the
hard light that we've you know the
bengal is creating or she's creating
whatever it is um
do we think they're gonna do sort of
like a closed loop time travel thing and
kamala's gonna go find her grandmother
and be like you need to get on this
train
or do you think that that is
purely a vision and
it's gonna be hard for her to interact
with anyone i think she's gonna be able
to interact i actually think that the
reason they can't remember how it
happened was her yeah i think that like
in this version of time travel because
remember in endgame they don't do the
they do timelines not interactivity so
i'm really curious if this is different
because we're introducing tva and kang
yeah is this a different is this not the
main timeline because like you know
theoretically if she went to another
timeline that would be a different
grandma because this isn't back to the
future rules some people online were
even speculating that she is her own
grandmother that does that gets really
complicated really the casting is good
enough like they look like you know like
that'd be a thing um yeah that would be
a thing
i was looking really closely to see if
the people in the world were looking at
her like she got like avoided and bumped
into that's all i could figure out
because i was doing the same i was like
eyes i was like can they see her or
because i don't know if you're moving
through a crowd and i guess you'd know
one person dodged and then one person
like actually avoided as she climbed up
but no one acknowledged her so it's
interesting they could kind of play it
both ways yeah
yeah um i i don't know where this is
going to lead to but you know if you're
looking at kind of previous disney plus
marvel shows that episode 5 you know we
spend all that time in the sort of
asylum or or the
sea of reads in
moon night
i think you know loki that was when we
were in the void
episode five seems to be like a really
central ship of theseus was uh one
division of fm reserves no i believe
that was her
uh the like her going through the doors
to her own oh you're right memories yeah
right so big episodes yeah so it's like
always this like hey we're gonna do this
flashback thing that gives you a lot of
background about your family here's the
content
yeah but but you know those are always
really impactful episodes of tv so i
can't wait for episode five of this show
um and i do think like
it's gonna it's gonna break us apart and
we're gonna we're gonna both cry and be
like holy [ __ ] this is like a crazy
thing that we didn't expect to be
happening i think we're gonna get bengal
information in the next episode that's
gonna tie into the greater mcu i do
think miss marvel's integral i still
think it's uh brian tyree henry's
character from maternals i forget
i think he's the one that invented the
ten rings and the bangle i think those
things tie together i think that's why
we saw the ten rings thank you fastos i
think fasto's invented both of those
things that's why we saw the ten rings
where the mango get picked up and i do
think we've already had a crease roll
war beforehand and then i think captain
marvel 2 is a creepy scroll war
happening again leading into secret
invasion so speaking of fafsa speaking
of this bangle
we saw it get sort of punctured or
whatever happened at the end of the
episode do you think that it's broken do
you think that you know we had that
scene with her and bruno in episode two
where bruno was sort of like well the
power is coming from you right the
bangle is sort of channeling it or
focusing it or whatever it was do we
think that bangle is broken
and then i'll ask you a question after
that
no okay
i think it was activated i don't think
it was broken oh i think it was like she
leveled up in power that was like awoken
i like that um
i think it
i thought
i thought someone was going to say yes
uh i do think i i think there's a
possibility that it it broke and
it breaking you know we don't know how
inhumans if they're going to be
introduced although this episode
yesterday i sat on the show was like
they're not doing any humans uh today
i'm like they're doing it in humans
because the gin being a thing that
aren't like i love the line about thor
and himalayas i love the line about like
and that's what i was saying in the show
yesterday too that the gods are a huge
thing and and correct me if i'm wrong
you're the comics expert i'm not i wish
jessica was here today um because she
loves miss marvel and miss marvel comics
is it not true that the inhumans sort of
like had a location in the himalayas in
the comics or maybe i missed so their
main locations on the moon that's right
but they do also have different spots
around the world to kind of supervise
and it wouldn't i don't remember
specifically the himalayas but it
wouldn't surprise me that somewhere
remote like that would call to them for
some reason that triggered in my brain
and yeah i just think a black bolt in
the moon being such a funny visual black
medusa just hanging out like
let's film it in hawaii on the moon um
so
i guess what i was going to say was you
know we don't really know how they're
going to do inhumans in this world is it
could be possible that this bengal does
break and that is what kind of causes
the pterogenesis process and then kamala
can use her powers sort of without this
focus
how do we feel about that
we love we loved it i loved the bangle
we were keeping the bangle if someone
steals it
uh
she has no powers i think that the
pterogenesis needs to activate something
in her and i do think that maybe there
is something amongst her family that is
inhuman like there is i mean there's a
bunch of freaking gas in the bangalore i
just don't think there's just bengals
all over the place like we need uh
we learned about the inscription on the
bengals as well what it said in this one
that you're chasing
seeking you or something like that which
is like her history i guess she's
seeking knowledge of her family which i
think that's her in time travel i think
that's why you don't think that's a fast
dose
fastest was like i'm gonna put a fortune
cookie thing on this well i think that
like he might be able to perceive that
oh sure so like maybe her going through
time is that what you seek is your own
self which could be the grandma thing
it's weird we'll see let's see um i
don't think yeah so if not fastos you
think maybe she is the person who
inscribed it or it's just possibly or do
you have any theories of who might have
i i i think that would be a little
strange just because she is such a
modern character that why would she
write it in such sort of a formal
ancient sort of way that's fair um but i
don't have like an alternate theory
really personally i i guess what is the
chat thing can i just get uh some some
people talking about dr doom in the
in the chat right now i have no idea why
um
um um who do you guys think maybe put
that inscription on the bangle in the
comments i want to hear from you guys i
guess eagle-eyed view if if we were
maybe doing our jobs right we would have
gone back to the episode where they
found the bangle on the arm and see if
they're yes even if the inscription
because it could have been but
it also like
am i crazy it like expanded yeah it
definitely changed in the first time and
i thought he had said i've not seen that
inscription before so it might have been
tough
she couldn't read it though so she
couldn't have read she couldn't have
written it because yeah
she goes back in time and is like taking
lessons or something
she's like i want to learn about my
family and i'm going to learn how to
read
yeah i feel like that is another
character we haven't met maybe it's cree
maybe it's another language like maybe
it's you know the the race that had the
blue hand i hate that this question was
asked
uh what are people more excited about dr
doom or barbie i only hate it because i
hate the answer
people are saying dr doom what kind of
show is this oh my god we don't talk
about marvel on this show we only talk
about barbie
um
no i understand
i understand i am disturbingly excited
for this barbie movie
the gossip scream man gotcha the gosling
scream a couple other uh polls that we
we put in the
uh in the chat i don't know if we
already went over these but people were
asked which would you rather see a house
of m adaptation or which is road
adaptation people are saying house of m
uh to be honest i think that's just
because most people are a little bit
more familiar with that run in the
comics although it is a very fun run and
we all want x-men um
let's see do you like the alternate
ending version of riva more or less than
the final version that would be funny
they they do the captain america thing
with avengers assembled where like it's
a different line reading that we all
expect so like avengers assembled and it
was like an impactful moment instead
there's a comma we don't see so scarlett
which goes no more more mutants and she
like activates the music like no more
mutes
i just thought of that as funny to make
him an interrupt um
it's okay that's what we're here for um
people were also asked if they would
prefer the alternate ending with riva to
the final version people really like
that alternate ending i want to just say
maybe it's because we're great
storytellers here on the break room
um
give us a movie give us a movie ready
a few more people soulgasm our good
friend said i knew what you meant john
no worries i'm assuming this has to do
with me talking about
it was your mixing up of the character's
last episode oh great hope you're still
watching we got to um
elijah bowser said um they could say
that wanda and pietro were adopted and
bring magneto in that way and then that
would be a cool way to bring him into
the fray there is a little bit of like
retconning that happened in the comics
where magnino was no longer the father
of pietro and wanda so it kind of seemed
like the mcu was like yeah we'll just
make up our own answer and and she got
her parents in sokovia
but there's no reason they can't say she
was adopted so yeah or you know
i don't know
magneto
yeah we also haven't met her parents
ever because it's the way that was all
navigated also in the multiverse
different people could be wandas so
there could be a multiverse where
magneto's kitties
i'm going to say that uh those two
people that were watching her and her
brother were just weird old babysitters
um
sean bell says bring doom in fantastic
four to make him grow inside the mcu i
don't really know what you're saying
with that um
maybe perhaps like introduce doom in
fantastic four and then like he he
doesn't finish there right like yeah
definitely loki in in avengers and then
his role was expanded so much or look i
guess look he started in thor but his
role has expanded so much in the mcu and
you could do a similar thing with
fantastic four black panthers black
panther is the end of this year and with
the howard stern timing i do think we're
probably gonna get a doom announcement
uh fairly soon which which unfortunately
might have kind of pushed them i would
rather them be able to do everything as
they planned but between d23 and
comic-con you think if they feel like
the
they need to say something they could
just wait what is it like three weeks
yeah i feel like comic-con is going to
be like we said yesterday a tease and
some announcements and then d23 is huge
yeah yeah it is too bad that
they were trying to save it for like a
post-credits scene or then again the
average person might not like we are in
a very specific place i always forget
how plugged in we all are like everyone
knows now there are so many people that
aren't watching the break room
unfortunately they should be but like
there are people that aren't i think
we're doing bigger numbers than the
super bowl you might just not be
familiar with how many viewers that's on
me everyone's here because
yeah that's right
barbie show bringing him in um you're
totally right you're totally right i
remember
the like doom tees that we got in
ant-man and the wasp like half the
theater was like oh my god it's doom and
half the theater was like
hooded figure great that was janet and
all the doom people were like oh it's
janet um
let's see uh
a couple more people someone said brian
cranston as doom we love brian cranston
as a villain who wouldn't want to see
that um
and then we have a couple of people who
maybe
thought uh a couple people who were
saying who wrote the script on the
bengal we have some people saying it was
celestial maybe even eternal whatever um
some people saying cree which obviously
makes a lot of sense there's not a cree
wrist uh we think
um
uh and someone's saying i think the
inscription was written by the cree
another another vote for creed what do
we think
do you think if
you're saying internals tech do we think
maybe cree tech on this side of the
table i'm kind of leaning cree tech um
i'll lean with you let's lean together
absolutely too crazy and eternal and we
could all be wrong decrees in a pod
we will find out
next week on the break room
um
thank you guys so much for hanging out
with us we will be back tomorrow we will
not be back on friday because we'll be
in austin having a great time some of us
are already there if you see philip
molino walking around
in a tight shirt and short shorts
slap his ass
and ryan gosling will scream very loudly
don't don't do that don't don't don't do
it
the super bowl level people watching
someone might not understand that was
just a barbie joke only thank you so
much for hanging out with us today we
will see you tomorrow where we will
exclusively be talking about barbie we
hope to see you guys there let's exit
with our famous morbid
line from the original script